the serial attacker put women at a North
Carolina military base on high alert the
disturbing crimes are the focus of
tonight's return of the CBS News series
48 hours NCIS the 48 hours team takes us
on the streets with the real NCIS agents
and real cases in CIS star rocky Carroll
plays the agency's director on the CBS
drama and in tonight's season premiere
of 48 hours NCIS he follows what it
takes to catch a dangerous criminal who
assaulted the loved ones of service
members the community of Jacksonville
North Carolina home to military base
Camp Lejeune was terrorized by a serial
rapist over a 14 month span beginning in
2011 there was a huge concern by the
Marine Corps the first victim was
Abilene wife Marianne who was attacked
in the middle of the night I was at home
with just my son while her husband was
deployed in Afghanistan I look up and
he's right there and he's charging at me
after the intruder sexually assaulted
Marianne he fled leaving behind few
clues it is believed that the
perpetrator was responsible for 12
sexual assaults five of those were
dependent wives more than a year after
Marianne was assaulted the investigators
developed their first significant lead
when Brianna Murphy was attacked I could
hear footsteps and then I just felt like
a big weight smack across my face and I
just immediately rolled over and I ran
Brianna's attacker vanished taking her
wallet with all her credit cards I think
she was very strong the suspect was
obviously very aggressive hours later he
moved on to his next victim Sarah her
husband had just left for work at the
base I saw a man in the entryway to my
bedroom he was just standing there with
a gun
at me NCIS and the Jacksonville Police
Department created a joint task force
that's when I kicked an overdrive
investigators would soon have videotape
of their suspect when he used Brianna
stolen credit cards
that was our real first investigative
lead let's go get him
I have a hunch that he's connected to
more ultimately it comes down to what
were able to prove I wanted to do
everything that I could to be part of
him being cop I needed to know that it
was done and that he couldn't hurt
anybody else
people think NCIS were just there for
the Marine Corps Navy we're there for
the war fighters and their families
that's what we're there for the new
season of 48 hours NCIS premieres
tonight at 10:00 p.m. 9:00 central right
here on CBS no that was rocky Carroll
but is it just me does he smell like
Bill Whitaker of 60 minutes mm-hmm very
good to me we'll have to have a test was
it really with yeah Rocky Whitaker a
rocker
rakia Laurel or Yaya that's right oh
goodness